IN ON THEIR RIGHTS IN ABORTION
RIGHTS.
IT WILL BE THE FIRST VOTE ON
ABORTION SINCE ROE WAS
OVERTURNED BY THE SUPREME COURT.
ON THE PRIMARY BALLOT AN
AMENDMENT TO THE KANSAS
CONSTITUTION THAT WOULD REMOVE
GUARANTEE PROTECTIONS FOR
ABORTION RIGHTS.
OUR GREATER REPORTS ARE BACK
WITH US.
WE CAN PUT UP ON THE SCREEN WHAT
THE BALLOT IS LIKE AND THE
LANGUAGE.
IN KANSAS A CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTION RIGHT FOR ABORTION
AND THIS SAY, QUOTE.
IT IS FASCINATING TO ME YOU HAVE
A RED STATE, DEMOCRATICGOVERNOR
BUT A STATE IN THE MIDDLE OF
AMERICA FIRST ON THE BALLOT.
THIS IS THE FIRST BIG TEST.
IS THIS ISSUE GOING TO BE A
GIANT TURNOUT MECHANISM?
>> IT IS FASCINATING.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF HURDLES AND
ISSUES GOING AGAINST THE
MOMENTUM BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
TOMORROW IS A PRIMARY DAY,
TRADITIONALLY LOWER TURNOUT.
IT WILL BE A REALLY FASCINATING
GAUGE OF WHETHER THIS MATTERS
EVEN IN A RED STATE AND,
OBVIOUSLY, REMEMBER THAT KANSAS
CITY AREA IS IN A CONSERVATIVE
STATE AND IT'S A INTERESTING
TESTING GROUND FOR A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES THE LAST --
>> DEMOCRATS ARE WONDERING WILL
THIS MOTIVATE OUR VOTES AND GET
BACK REPUBLICAN LEADING WOMEN IN
THE SUBURBS AND INDEPENDENTS WHO
MAYBE BECAUSE OF INFLATION OR
WHATEVER OTHER REASON WERE
PLANNING TO VOTE AGAINST JOE
BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS.
DOES IT GIVE THEM PAUSE THAT IS
A BIG TEST.
>> NOBODY KNOWS.
ABORTION HAS BEEN A REAL
MOTIVATING ISSUE FOR REPUBLICANS
AND NOT SO MUCH FOR DEMOCRATS
BUT THE DEMOCRATS I'VE TALKED TO
THE ONES WHO ARE LISTENING TO
RANK AND FILE VOTERS AND YOUNG
VOTERS IN PARTICULAR, THIS IS A
MOTIVATING FACTOR FOR THEM.
NOW THAT ROE V. WADE HAS BEEN
OVERTURNED IN THE COUNTRY THEY
THINK THEY HAVE SEEN ALREADY A
MOMENTUM THAT, YOU KNOW, THEY
HOPE THEY CAN SUSTAIN IN
NOVEMBER.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
NOT ONLY AMONG YOUNG VOTERS BUT
ALSO THESE SUBURBAN WHITE WOMEN
SWING VOTERS, RIGHT, WHO, AS YOU
SAID, IN SOME WAYS, MIGHT SWING
BACK TO REPUBLICANS.
TRADITIONALLY I'VE BEEN IN
REPUBLICAN COLUMNS, BUT HAVE,
OVER THE LAST CYCLES, REALLY
SHOWN UP FOR DEMOCRATS.
CAN THEY KEEP THAT GOING?
SO THIS WILL BE A TEST FOR THEM.
>> FROM A MESSAGING PERSPECTIVE,
I THINK WHY DEMOCRATS ARE
FINDING THEY ARE HAVING SOME
SUCCESS HERE IN GALVANIZING
THEIR VOTERS IS THE WAY THAT
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THIS.
RIGHT?
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT ABORTION
AS A MATTER OF HEALTH CARE.
SOMETIMES AS A MATTER OF LIFE
SAVING CARE.
I'M COVERING THE GEORGIA SENATE
AND GOVERNOR RACES AND STACEY
ABRAMS A FEW DAYS SPEAKING TO
HER FOLKS SAID BALANCE YOUR
CONCERNS ABOUT MONEY, INFLATION
THERE.
OUTWEIGH YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT
YOUR CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTED
RIGHTS.
I THINK IT'S IN THE MESSAGING
AND HOW THEY ARE PACKAGING THIS
IS WHY WE ARE SEEING JUST THIS
RUSH OF PEOPLE, I THINK, SO
MOTIVATED TO VOTE.
>> SO THAT IS PART OF THE KEY
TEST.
CAN CANDIDATES EFFECTIVELY MAKE
THE ARGUMENT IN THE WAY THAT
FITS YOUR STATE?
A LOT OF LIBERALS IN GEORGIA BUT
MORE CONSERVE VOTERS IN GEORGIA.
KANSAS HAS A DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR
BUT IT'S A PRETTY CONSERVATIVE
TATE.
HERE IS ONE PIECE OF EVIDENCE.
AS OF 6:00 A.M. THIS MORNING,
EARLY VOTING, EARLY VOTING BOTH
IN PERSON AND MAIL-IN VOTING IS
UP.
NOW THE COVID ELECTION YEAR 2020
IN THE MIDDLE THERE.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE BECOME MORE
ACCUSTOMED TO EARLY VOTING.
STILL A GIANT JUMP FROM THE LAST
MIDTERM ELECTION TO THIS ONE
THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING, YEA OR NAY, BUT THAT
TELLS YOU SOMETHING.
>> IT IS REALLY FASCINATING JUST
TO SEE THE INTEREST IN THAT.
I DO THINK, THOUGH, HOWEVER,
WHATEVER ENERGY WE SEE TOMORROW
ON THE ABORTION ISSUE, I STILL
THINK IT IS A BIG QUESTION HOW
MUCH THAT MATTERS WHEN YOU
BEFORE I IN OTHER ISSUES, WHICH
VOTERS WILL BE VOTING ON IN
NOVEMBER.
BECAUSE, OBVIOUSLY, IT WON'T BE
JUST ABORTION, IT WOULD BE THE
ECONOMY AND IT WOULD BE
INFLATION AND PERHAPS OTHER
ISSUES.
SO HOW ABORTION ACCESS GETS
PRIORITIZED WITH THOSE OTHER
ISSUES, I THINK, IT'S A QUESTION
THAT WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
BE ASKING.
>> WHY THIS ONE STATE IS SUCH A
GREAT LABORATORY BECAUSE
EVERYONE WILL REACT TO THIS.
REPUBLICANS WILL FIGURE OUT HOW
TO COUNTER IT AND GETS YOU TO
OTHER ISSUES.
KATIE WROTE THIS ABOUT "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" ON SUNDAY.
REPUBLICANS INSIST THAT ANGER
AROUND INFLATION IN FEAR OF A
RECESSION WILL CROWD OUT OTHER
CONCERNS FOR A BROAD SWATH OF
VOTERS.
QUOTE.
DEMOCRATS ARE TELLING YOU NOW
THAT THEY THINK THE CLIMATE IS
BETTER THAN IT WAS A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO BECAUSE THEY DO THINK
THIS WILL BE MOTIVATING.
YOU CAN SAY THAT.
HERE IS A TEST.
>> RUN OF THE REASONS IT'S
MOTIVATING IS DEMOCRATS ARE
ANGRY, RIGHT?
IF YOU'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS, THERE HAVE BEEN
THESE TERRIBLE CASES, RIGHT, OF
THE GIRL FROM OHIO WHO HAD TO GO
TO INDIANA.
SHE WAS 10 YEARS OLD AND SHE WAS
RAPED AND IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR
HER TO GET AN ABORTION.
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF CASES
THAT I THINK WILL PROBABLY
LIKELY SEE MORE OF, THE IDEA
THAT, YOU KNOW, MAYBE IF YOU
HAVE A MISCARRIAGE OR SOMETHING,
THERE ARE ALL OF THESE
SCENARIOS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT WOMEN WHO ARE
POOR AND NOT ACCESS TO ABORTION
BUT IT COULD AFFECT ANY WOMAN IN
ANY STATE IF ABORTION ACCESS IS
RESTRICTED.
SO YOU'RE SEEING, I THINK,
EMOTIONS AROUND THIS AND THAT
TERMS OF HELP TO MOTIVATE
VOTERS.
>> YOU CAN SEE PENNSYLVANIA
SUBURB RACE, MATTERS.
OTHER PLACES TOO.
ANY OTHER PLACES ON THE MAP THIS
HAPPENED IN KANSAS.
LET'S WATCH OUT HERE.
>> RIGHT, RIGHT.
I THINK THE IMPACT PARTICULARLY
ON THE SENATE RACES WILL BE
REALLY INTERESTING BECAUSE SO
MANY OF THE SENATE BATTLE
GROUNDS THIS YEAR ARE PLACES
WHERE VOTERS TEND TO BE MORE
SUPPORTIVE OF ABORTION RIGHTS SO
THAT'S WHY YOU'VE SE